what was like for you the breaking point
where you were like i gotta get the [ __ ]
take care of this [ __ ] man oh i had um
like the fight club stuff was going on i
had a development deal with shady
records it was like your names you love
your music like
but you're going in and out of jail
because i would do besides the the main
[ __ ] i would do like little skid bids
like i would go to rikers for two weeks
so vikings for a month come out yo
you're going in and out of jail we take
you to places sometimes you don't show
up when you do show up you [ __ ] you
run outside you rob people outside the
studio you're doing like i was just like
living crazy like wow yeah yeah it's
just
you never had any uh instances where you
thought you might have overdosed or
gotten close to it
that's a lot of drugs like this
back then it wasn't like the fentanyl
[ __ ] now like you know i'm saying it was
it was different and i never oh and when
i dealt with people i dealt with people
i knew that i grew up with from coney
island you know what i'm saying like and
there wasn't like
luckily i didn't have to go through none
of that was that getting off of the [ __ ]
hard going through withdrawals and it
was but the last year two of my of my my
addiction i was like yo i didn't want to
do it it was just more like a job it was
like yo if i'm ever able to stop doing
this for a couple days when i'm not sick
anymore like i'm never gonna do this
again i'm so tired of living this
lifestyle but i also had given up on my
dreams with the rap [ __ ] like i i didn't
want i didn't care about nothing but
getting high like and then it just had
like a moment of clarity one day
i was on like a three-week run like i
hadn't slept i hadn't
showered none of that and i was like had
like a i don't know if it was psychosis
or like i had a body experience when i
was like i could keep going how i'm
going right now and i'm gonna be dead or
i'm gonna be in jail the rest of my life
from doing something stupid
or i could just stop right now and live
my dreams
like like i had already given up on my
dreams and that night
i went to my mother's house she was
living in staten island i was in coney
island at the time i was like yo ma
please let me just stay at your house
she was like nah you can't she been not
letting me right right she knew you
wasn't yeah yeah she was but something
she let me stay and uh
i just kept the wheels going i stopped
one day
two i had to go through it and when i
got through it though
i never touched nothing again nothing no
not a drink not weed nothing
so you've been totally sober yeah 12
years nothing nothing wow that's best
that's real big man yeah yeah yeah and
and the evidence is there since i
stopped that my whole [ __ ] life is
you know like i bought my mom's a house
got me a house i got [ __ ] right now
they're putting us in ground salt water
pool in my backyard right now they're
doing it as we speak and and uh you're
still in coney island no no no i bought
a house of staten island okay which is
like 20 minutes right now um it's close
enough that when i want to hang out and
be a be you know be a her booger do hood
stuff with my hood friends you know what
i'm saying like yeah we we can move over
there and um and when i want to be left
alone go to the crib go to the crib
that's it